c'est une escalade verbale qui précipite
les relations russo américaines dans une
nouvelle spirale de tension alors que le
centième jour de la nouvelle
administration démocrate arrive à grands
pas ces trois premiers mois donnent
généralement des indices sur le style de
gouvernance d'un nouveau locataire de la
maison blanche
celui de joe biden semble peu à peu se
dessiner concernant le ton des relations
que washington compte entretenir avec
moscou dans une interview accordée à la
chaîne américaine nbc joe biden avait
qualifié son homologue russe de tueurs
ce à quoi a répondu vladimir poutine par
une pirouette avant de proposer au
président américain de débattre en
direct
nous ne devons pas échangé dans le dos
de l'autre nous pouvons et nous devons
poursuivre une relation ne sera pas
d'augmentation prochain d'ailleurs j'y
ai pensé la dernière fois que nous avons
une conversation téléphonique
l'initiative est venue du président
biden je voudrais proposer au président
buydens poursuivre notre discussion mais
à condition que nous fassions en direct
en ligne comme on dit il s'agirait d'une
discussion ouverte en direct il nous
pourrions parler des relations
bilatérales de la stabilité stratégique
estime olé schell et du traitement des
conflits régionaux et il y en a beaucoup
tegan and conflict afrique une
proposition pour le moment ignorés par
washington la porte parole de la maison
blanche indiquant seulement que joe
biden voyage ce vendredi et se trouve
actuellement très occupé
moscou qui qualifie ces propos d'
insulte envers la population russe a
rappelé son ambassadeur aux etats-unis
pour consultations
vladimir poutine a annoncé défendre les
intérêts de la russie être prêt à
coopérer avec les américains
si les conditions sont avantageuses une
déclaration approuvée par washington
le président mbaye d'année le président
poutine ont certainement des points de
vue différents sur leurs pays respectifs
sur la manière d'aborder leur engagement
dans le monde
mais là où ils sont d'accord c'est que
nous devons continuer à coopérer à
chercher des moyens de travailler
ensemble comme cela a été exprimé dans
les commentaires du président poutine
il y à des domaines d'intérêt mutuel
cette passe d'armes verbale a été suivi
des sanctions supplémentaires à
l'encontre de la russie anthony blinken
le chef de la diplomatie américaine a de
plus appelé les entités impliquées dans
le projet de gazoduc nord stream 2 à se
désengager de l'accord sous peine de
sanctions des etats-unis